« Alors, c'était comment ? »
Qu'il s'agisse de votre récent passage chez le dentiste
ou du dernier concert de votre idole,
quand on vous pose cette petite question
(« Alors, c'était comment ? »),
c'est pour essayer d'avoir votre ressenti sur l'expérience
(positive ou négative) que vous avez vécue ;
à quel point vous en gardez
un souvenir agréable ou désagréable.
Mais est-ce que c'est la même chose d'avoir apprécié
un moment, et d'en garder un bon souvenir ?
Le souvenir des bons ou des mauvais moments,
c'est important : c'est tout ce qu'il nous reste à la fin.
L'expérience qu'on a vécue, la sensation instantanée
qu'on a eue à ce moment-là, c'était temporaire ;
alors que le souvenir, lui, demeure.
Dans les années 90,
le psychologue Daniel Kahneman
s'est intéressé à ce qu'on retenait
de nos expériences, positives et négatives.
Et il a obtenu quelques résultats plutôt contrintuitifs.
Pour examiner les souvenirs
que l'on garde d'un épisode désagréable,
Daniel Kahneman a travaillé avec un médecin
qui faisait passer des coloscopies.
Je vous passe les détails, mais la coloscopie
(un examen de l'intérieur du côlon),
n'est pas connue pour être une des expériences
les plus agréables qui soient.
À l'époque de l'étude (c'était au Canada),
on la pratiquait principalement sous anesthésie légère.
Et Kahneman a voulu comprendre
l'évolution de la douleur ressentie
par ceux qui subissaient cet examen.
Pour cela, il a utilisé 154 vrais patients
qui devaient passer une coloscopie.
Ceux-ci disposaient, pendant l'examen, d'un petit boîtier
leur permettant de faire varier sur un écran
un curseur pour indiquer
le niveau de douleur qu'ils ressentaient.
Et ils avaient pour instruction
de le faire toutes les minutes,
sachant que l'examen pouvait durer
entre cinq minutes et plus d'une heure.
Grâce à cela,
Kahneman a pu récupérer pour les 154 patients
une courbe indiquant l'évolution
de leur douleur au cours de l'examen.
Voici deux exemples de courbes obtenues
pour deux patients différents.
En regardant ces deux courbes, à votre avis,
lequel des deux patients a le plus souffert au total ?
On a tous envie de penser que c'est le patient B.
Eh bien pour le savoir,
en plus de cette notation en temps réel,
Kahneman a demandé aux patients, une fois l'examen
terminé et qu'ils étaient revenus dans leur chambre,
de noter leur expérience.
La question était :
« Sur une échelle de 1 à 10,
comment évaluez-vous la quantité totale d'inconfort
que vous avez ressentie au cours de l'examen ? »
Et il leur a aussi reposé cette question
à nouveau, mais un mois plus tard.
Intuitivement, on a envie de penser
que cette quantité totale d'inconfort
doit être liée à la fois la durée
et à l'intensité de la douleur,
et corresponde plus ou moins
à l'aire sous la courbe.
Et que donc, par exemple,
sur ces deux patients A et B,
le patient B aurait vécu globalement une expérience
plus désagréable que le patient A.
Ce qu'a constaté Kahneman, c'est que la note globale
dépendait principalement de deux choses :
l'intensité maximale de la douleur
ressentie au cours de l'examen,
et le niveau de douleur à la fin de l'examen –
dans les trois dernières minutes.
Ce que vous voyez ici,
ce sont les coefficients de corrélation
entre, d'un côté, les évaluations globales
juste après l'examen et un mois plus tard,
et de l'autre, l'intensité maximale,
l'intensité finale et la durée de l'examen.
Pour ceux qui ne sont pas familiers
avec l'idée le coefficient de corrélation,
quand c'est proche de zéro
il n'y a pas de corrélation,
et plus on se rapproche de 1
plus la corrélation est forte.
Ici, on voit donc que les notes globales sont très
corrélées à l'intensité maximale et à l'intensité finale,
mais pas à la durée de l'examen.
C'est ce que Kahneman
a appelé la loi de l'apogée/fin :
ce que les gens retiennent
d'une expérience douloureuse,
c'est son intensité à son apogée
et son intensité à la fin.
Mais la durée joue très peu.
C'est quand même perturbant de penser que
le patient B, avec cette courbe de douleur,
a gardé un moins mauvais souvenir
de son examen que le patient A,
alors qu'il a objectivement plus souffert.
Une explication qu'on peut envisager,
c'est que les patients ont probablement du mal
à prendre en compte la durée pour attribuer leur note.
Parce qu'ils ne s'imaginent pas forcément que
l'examen aurait pu être plus court sur le plan médical,
alors qu'ils peuvent facilement concevoir
qu'il aurait pu être moins douloureux .
Mais à ce sujet, Kahneman a fait
une autre étude encore plus perturbante.
Il a reçu des sujets en leur disant
qu'ils allaient faire trois expériences.
Première expérience : plonger une de leurs mains
dans de l'eau à 14°C pendant 60 secondes.
L'expérience n'est pas hyper-agréable,
mais c'est supportable quand même.
À l'issue des 60 secondes, on leur offrait
une serviette chaude pour se sécher la main.
Deuxième expérience : plonger leur autre main
dans de l'eau à 14°C pendant 60 secondes (pareil),
puis dans de l'eau à 15°C pendant 30 secondes.
Et à la fin, enfin : serviette chaude.
Point de méthodes important : l'ordre de ces
deux expériences était tiré au hasard pour chaque sujet.
Certains faisaient d'abord la plus longue,
d'autres la plus courte.
Les mains aussi étaient choisies aléatoirement
Après avoir fait ces deux expériences,
Kahneman leur annonçait que la troisième expérience
serait de refaire l'une des deux précédentes,
mais celle de leur choix.
En principe, entre 60 secondes à 14°C
et 60 secondes à 14°C puis 30 secondes à 15°C,
y a pas photo, hein !
La première provoque objectivement
moins de désagréments,
donc 100 % des gens auraient dû choisir
de répéter celle-ci.
Et pourtant, 70 % des gens ont préféré répéter
la deuxième expérience – la plus longue.
On retrouve ce qu'on a vu avec la coloscopie :
il semble que la durée ne rentre
pas tellement ligne de compte,
mais que le fait que l'expérience
se termine plus progressivement
aide à atténuer le souvenir douloureux
même si la quantité totale de douleur
est objectivement plus importante.
On peut obtenir ce type de résultats pas seulement
avec des événements désagréables,
mais aussi les évènements agréables.
Pour faire la comparaison, des chercheurs ont réalisé
le même genre d'expérience que la coloscopie,
mais avec des gens regardant des séquences vidéo.
Les sujets devaient noter en temps réel
leur niveau de plaisir ou de déplaisir
alors qu'ils regardaient des petits films,
soient particulièrement agréables
(des animaux qui jouent, par exemple),
soit particulièrement désagréables
(genre des amputations).
Il existait plusieurs types de films
dans chaque catégorie,
et chaque film existait
en deux durées différentes.
Comme pour la coloscopie :
en plus de l'évaluation en temps réel, les sujets
ont dû noter à la fin leur expérience globale.
En regardant à nouveau les corrélations,
il a été montré que c'était l'intensité maximale
et l'intensité finale qui étaient
les plus liées à la note globale –
tandis que la durée ne jouait aucun rôle,
en particulier pour les films agréables.
Des effets du même genre ont également été montrés
pour ce qu'on retient d'un bon repas :
la fin est particulièrement importante ;
ou bien nos vacances, pour lesquelles
la durée ne compte pas tant que ça.
Autre exemple intéressant,
surtout pour ceux qui ont un business :
des chercheurs ont montré
qu'on gardait un meilleur souvenir
d'une file d'attente qui commence lentement
puis s'accélère, que l'inverse.
même si la durée totale a été plus importante.
Ce qu'il se passe à la fin
compte plus que la durée.
Si on élargit un peut, on se dit que
ça peut aussi s'appliquer à des œuvres d'art :
l'important est de soigner l'apogée et la fin.
Je donne deux exemples qui ne respectent pas
cette règle, et que je trouve assez intéressants.
Pour ceux qui ont lu Le seigneur des anneaux,
ça se termine par une grande bataille épique,
mais qui n'est pas la dernière du livre.
Il reste après un chapitre un peu bizarre
où les hobbits retournent libérer La Comté
et qui m'a donné une espèce de sentiment étrange,
parce que le combat a l'air complètement ridicule
à côté de ce qu'on vient de vivre avant.
Au lieu de se terminer en apothéose
sur l'affrontement du gros boss de fin,
on termine sur une espèce de sous-bataille
et on se demande ce qu'elle fait là.
D'ailleurs, je crois que Peter Jackson
a viré ce passage dans le film.
Autre exemple plus récent : La La Land.
Le film commence par une scène
absolument incroyable
à la fin de laquelle je suis resté
scotché sur mon siège.
Le problème,
c'est qu'à aucun moment – à mon avis –
le film n'a retrouvé cette intensité
qu'il y a dans la scène d'ouverture.
En gros, le réalisateur a lâché tous les chevaux
dans les trois premières minutes,
et je m'attendais à retrouver ça
au milieu ou à la fin... Eh ben non !
Du coup, le film m'a laissé
une espèce d'impression de « moyen-bof ».
Il y a plein d'autres cas :
pensez à ces séries qui n'arrivent pas à finir.
Du coup, même si vous avez apprécié
la première saison, vous en gardez un souvenir moyen.
On pourrait faire le même genre de raisonnement
avec les mariages qui se terminent en divorces.
Mais bon, comme je ne suis pas plus
conseiller matrimonial que critique de film,
on va revenir à la science !
Un truc récurrent qu'on a vu,
c'est que la durée de l'expérience semble ne pas
compter dans notre évaluation rétrospective.
Comme si on n'avait pas de difficulté
à juger la qualité,
mais qu'on était assez mauvais
pour mesurer les quantités, les durées.
Dans son livre Thinking fast and slow,
Kahneman explique cela en disant que, dans plein
de situations où il faut décider de quelque chose,
notre cerveau ne fait pas
une analyse rationnelle complète
mais fonctionne avec ce qu'on appelle des heuristiques,
c'est-à-dire des raccourcis permettant d'avoir
rapidement une réponse sans trop se planter.
Et manifestement, nos heuristiques prennent
plus facilement en compte la qualité que la quantité.
Et il y a une expérience amusante
qui l'illustre bien.
Des chercheurs ont demandé à des participants
d'évaluer la valeur à leurs yeux d'un service de vaisselle,
c'est-à-dire combien ils seraient prêts
à payer pour l'acheter.
Un premier service comportait 24 pièces :
il y avait huit grandes assiettes,
huit bols et huit petites assiettes à dessert.
Et un second service, totalement identique,
mais avec en plus huit tasses et huit soucoupes.
Sauf que deux tasses
et sept soucoupes été ébréchées.
Quand on leur présentait les deux ensemble,
les participants attribuaient au second service
une valeur supérieure au premier –
ce qui est assez rationnel puisqu'il contient exactement
la même chose, mais avec des trucs en plus.
Mais quand on leur présentait séparément les deux,
c'était au premier service qu'ils attribuaient
en moyenne une valeur supérieure.
Ils jugeaient ou prenaient plus facilement
en compte la qualité que la quantité.
Toutes ces questions de souvenirs que l'on garde
d'une file d'attente ou nos vacances
peuvent vous sembler assez anecdotiques.
Mais si on vient à l'exemple de l'examen médical,
on voit que ça pose quand même quelques problèmes.
Souvenez-vous des courbes
de douleur des patients A et B.
Si, de façon contrintuitive,
le patient B a conservé un meilleur souvenir
de son examen que le patient A,
ne devrait-on pas prolonger artificiellement
l'examen du patient A ?
C'est facile :
il suffirait de rester quelques minutes de plus
en essayant de lui faire un peu mal mais pas trop.
À la fin, c'est assez paradoxal :
cela signifie lui infliger artificiellement une souffrance
supplémentaire n'ayant aucune justification médicale,
juste pour qu'il garde un bon souvenir de son examen.
Kahneman a d'ailleurs proposé cette expérience
à des médecins réalisant des coloscopies,
et effectivement : ceux dont on avait
artificiellement prolongé l'examen de trois minutes
conservaient un meilleur souvenir.
Tout cela pose quand même
quelques problèmes d'éthique.
Est-ce qu'un médecin peut infliger
de la souffrance inutile
avec comme seule motivation de laisser
un meilleur souvenir au patient ?
C'est quand même très discutable.
Comme disait Hippocrate : « Primum non nocere »
(« Premièrement, ne pas nuire »).
On pourrait trancher le débat en disant que l'important,
c'est la santé du patient et pas son bon souvenir.
Donc non.
Sauf que ça devient plus compliqué
si on prend en compte que le souvenir
plus ou moins douloureux d'un examen
va jouer un rôle sur le fait que le patient
revienne faire cet examen plus tard.
Dans le cas des coloscopies,
que certains patients doivent faire
à intervalle régulier pour du dépistage,
c'est évidemment important
qu'ils aient « envie » de revenir.
On peut donc se demander si un médecin a le droit
d'infliger un peu de souffrance inutile en fin d'examen
au nom de la santé future de son patient.
Eh bien, je pense que c'est
une question d'éthique qui est compliquée,
et ça me semble suffisamment intense
pour conclure cette vidéo en beauté.
Merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo !
Si elle vous a plu, n'hésitez pas à la partager, surtout
avec ceux qui ne connaissent pas déjà la chaîne.
Vous pouvez vous abonner (la cloche !),
les actus de la chaîne : Facebook et Twitter,
vous pouvez me soutenir sur Tippeee.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt
pour de nouvelles vidéos !